on y va
c'est bonjour
la victoire
depuis deux ans je me dis pour europe
ecologie les verts j'invite toute la
genèse à prendre conscience de l'urgence
climatique et ne pas laisser les autres
personnes décider à leur place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
elijah d'eau dont c'est le seul qui
porte haut et fort donc les couleurs
vertes en fait est là pour le coup donc
c'est vraiment très représentative et on
a on peut justement l'affirmé on est
légitime de montrer du verre sur les
affiches de la campagne
[Musique]
pas entendu que renault est belle il
avait monté un comité citoyen pour râler
complaisez zine qui sont choqués aux
normes a alors qu'ils ont déjà 110 des
accidents tous les toutes les semaines
tous les villages alentours et puis un
but avec les vagues de chaleur qui ont
augmenté ces dernières années avec le
dérèglement climatique c'est une vraie
catastrophe dans le milieu est vraiment
sensible pour voir des dauphins ici non
et le gouvernement n'a pas l'air non
plus extrêmement motivés à mettre de
réel plan d'action concret on va voir la
biodiversité qui est ici tout le monde
se plaint de la qualité de l'air quand
l'air plus quand le ciel est orange et
tous les soirs pendant une semaine parce
qu'ils sont en train de
brûler je ne sais quel produit
personne enfin qui a envie de vivre dans
un climat d' apocalypse entre la fumée
la lumière vraiment certains soirs ça
fait peur
[Musique]
je vais réaliser une lessive 100% fait
maison avec des produits écoresponsables
et naturel que dans les lessives que
l'on retrouve classique il ya des
perturbateurs endocriniens nous perturbe
aussi nos voies respiratoires ça peut
être irritant pour la peau il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui font des
allergies à cause de ça et puis aussi
bien tout ce qui parle dans la machine à
laver va être un moment donné retourner
du coup à la terre à l'eau et ça peut
polluer justement la biodiversité marine
et mollusques etc
c'est très bien que l'écologie soit
venir est là notre problème si vous
différencier notre engagement personnel
et l'engagement politique et le problème
c'est que beaucoup de partis en fait et
c'est de mettre du vert sur le papier
mais en réalité il ya peu de choses qui
sont faites on est en train de vivre à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui les conséquences
d'il ya 20 ans dans 20 ans vivra les
conséquences que l'on inflige ainsi à
notre planète aujourd'hui pour moi oui
on est en train de reculer c'est pour ça
que l'urgence climatique et la première
urgence à prendre en compte avant le
reste était pour moi que c'est une
priorité aux élections présidentielles
parce que tout se joue aujourd'hui c'est
très important de prendre mousse
mesdames
et dans un bon jour
yannick jadot candidat au prix la cause
d'al qods
pour insee c'est un peu plus juste et
puis surtout un mètre de plus d'écologie
avait plus de vert dans notre société
j'ai vu ce que vous en pensez
que du bien il voulait un peu plus de
verre
générales
et présidentielle un candidat écologiste
sur l'avenir de nos enfants et puis
notre santé que vous angoisser quand je
suis mélenchon 1 vous et moi c'est pas
con boîte en boîte mais pas pour lui et
vous mesdames qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je m'en fous
honnêtement je crois voilà mais ça il
faut exprimer exprimer votre
bien je vous laisse du coup
c'est gentil mais dieu merci aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous pensez à vous de
l'écologie
wiiware c'est un succès important
c'est john un peu comme moi il manque
pense que pour tous les jeunes justement
pas perdurer l'avouer c'est important
pour notre
ça me fait plaisir de rencontrer
la jeunesse lorsque je tracte parce que
souvent elles sont elle est sensible aux
problèmes d'écologie mais elles ont pas
encore ce déclic justement allé
s'exprimer par le vote et ben non
justement je suis là pour leur donner
cette motivation et leur donner
confiance en elle à aller justement
s'exprimer et aller au bout de leur
objectif pour une visite et un peu plus
juste et surtout mettre réellement le
plus de verre dans nos sociétés on va
déjà de
lui seul objectif c'est réduire les
impacts négatifs sur l'environnement des
entreprises et de l'autre côté essayer
de favoriser le malade a conquis
tout à fait on est des vitrolles et je
pense qu on est malheureusement mais
lugano de
pollution laquelle être en devenir
marignale j'ignore ingénieurs la mère de
sky sports ça reste calé stagnant en
effet oui quand on regarde nos réseaux
ces
évolutions dans ce cas pas de vent ça
fait peur pour moi tracts et ça me
permet aussi d'essayer de redonner de
l'espoir aux personnes qui pensent que
l'écologie
c'est important mais qui n'y croient
plus non non yannick jadot et là il
pourra lui mettre en place de mesures
concrètes et bien un avenir plus juste
voilà mais cool de colombie
[Musique]